***
Verehrtes Publikum,
meine Damen und Herren.
Wir befinden uns auf dem Landsitz
von Miss Sophie.
As every year
feiert sie hier ihren Geburtstag.
muss ihr Butler James
die Getränke der 4 mittlerweile
verstorbenen Gäste trinken.
Doch wie betrunken müsste James
dann eigentlich sein?
Das klärt nun für Sie
kein Geringerer als Jack Pop.
Und jetzt: Viel Vergnügen!
*Applaus*
Tag zusammen, Jack Pop hier.
Ich bin froh, dass ich nicht
das alles trinken muss,
was Butler James
bei "Dinner For One" so runterkippt.
Aber man fragt sich: Wie viel
Promille hat der am Ende des Abends?
*Er lallt.*
Dann lasst uns mal
Schritt für Schritt durchrechnen,
wie viel Promille James
im Verlaufe des Abends haben müsste.
Mit diesem Online-Promille-Rechner.
Der wurde
von einem Verkehrspsychologen
mit einem Team aus Ärztinnen
und Ärzten entwickelt.
Der wird auch
von der Dekra empfohlen.
Also ein zuverlässiges Tool.
Und v.a. können wir hier
alle Variablen eintragen,
die es braucht,
um den genauen Wert zu errechnen.
Wir brauchen die Größe von James,
sein Gewicht, sein Alter,
Geschlecht ist klar.
Und dann das, was er vorher
an diesem Abend gegessen hat.
Der Schauspieler Freddie Frinton
war nicht besonders groß.
Die genaue Größe
konnten wir nicht rausfinden.
Aber hier sehen wir, dass er etwa
so groß ist wie Miss Sophie.
Wir wissen, dass die Schauspielerin
May Warden 1,51 m groß ist.
Was das Gewicht angeht, er ist
nicht besonders dick oder dünn.
Also lass uns mal mit einem
Durchschnittswert von 60 kg rechnen.
Dann brauchen wir noch das Alter.
Zum Zeitpunkt der Aufzeichnung
war Freddie Frinton 54 Jahre alt.
Aber bevor ihr schimpft, weil er
in der Aufzeichnung älter aussieht:
Wir haben das auch mit einem Alter
um die 90 Jahre durchgerechnet.
Das macht Promille-technisch
keinen großen Unterschied.
Deswegen tragen wir hier
die 54 Jahre ein.
Und wir schauen noch darauf,
was er vorher gegessen hat.
It's the same procedure
as every year.
Der wusste, was auf ihn zukommt.
Deswegen wird der sich ordentlich
was angefuttert haben.
Nun gehen wir das Dinner
Gang für Gang durch.
Und schauen,
was der Butler da wirklich trinkt.
James, Sie dürfen
die Suppe servieren.
Cheerio, Miss Sophie.
Admiral von Schneider.
Must I say it this year,
Miss Sophie?
Just to please me.
- Just to please you.
Skal.
*Lachkonserve*
Mr. Pommeroy.
- Happy New Year, Sophie.
*Lachkonserve*
And dear Mr. Winterbottom.
Well, here we are again, luvee.
*Lachkonserve*
Wer mitgezählt hat, hat gesehen:
James hat sich 4 Sherry
hinter die Binde gekippt.
Aber wir sehen nicht, wie viel
Flüssigkeit in den Bechern ist.
Die sind nicht durchsichtig.
Aber wir sehen auch, James kippt es
nicht mit einem Schluck runter.
Von daher gehen wir einfach mal
von einem gut gefüllten Schnapsglas
von 4 cl aus.
Dann müssen wir noch wissen,
wie viel Umdrehungen Sherry hat.
Das sind 15-22% Alkohol.
Da nehmen wir grob die Mitte,
also 18%.
Wenn wir das
in unseren Rechner eingeben,
dann haben 4 mal 4 cl,
das ergibt 0,16 Liter.
Wenn wir das ausrechnen,
kommen wir in der 1. Runde
auf einen Pegel von 0,3 Promille.
Das ist etwas weniger,
als ich gedacht hätte.
Aber was heißt das eigentlich genau?
Da fragen wir am besten mal 2 Ärzte.
Nämlich die Jungs
von NERDfall-Medizin.
Also 0,3 Promille
klingt nicht dramatisch.
Und meistens ist es das auch nicht.
Aber auch schon
bei dieser Blutalkoholkonzentration
sinkt unsere Aufmerksamkeit.
Wir sehen etwas schlechter,
die Konzentration ist nicht so gut.
Unsere Risikobereitschaft steigt
und unsere Reaktionsfähigkeit
nimmt ab.
Hm, es geht so langsam los.
Das ist diese Schwelle,
wo Leute, die normal trinken,
den Alkohol
zum ersten Mal richtig merken.
Nicht ohne Grund ist es so:
Wenn wir mit 0,3 Promille
erwischt werden
und vielleicht
etwas auffällig fahren,
kann unser Führerschein weg sein.
Wenn wir einen Unfall bauen,
geht es Richtung Gefängnisstrafe.
Bitte gar nicht fahren,
wenn ihr was getrunken habt.
Ich habe es mal
für mich ausgerechnet:
Bei mir würden schon
1,5 Gläser Wein reichen,
um diese 0,3 Promille zu erreichen.
Darum würde ich meine Freunde
immer bequatschen,
dass sie sich bitte ein Taxi nehmen
statt Auto zu fahren.
Andere gehen so weit,
dass sie den Leuten sogar
die Autoschlüssel wegnehmen.
Was denkt ihr? Ist das übergriffig
oder absolut gerechtfertigt?
Schreibt mir das in die Kommentare.
Und wir servieren
hier jetzt den Fisch.
Sir Toby.
- Cheerio, Sophie, my gal.
Admiral von Schneider.
- Oh, must I, Miss Sophie?
James, please.
Skal.
*Lachkonserve*
*Lachen*
Mr. Pommeroy.
Happy New Year, Sophie, lass.
*Lachen*
*lautes Lachen*
Mr. Winterbottom.
*Er fängt schon an zu lallen.*
*Lachen*
(lallend)
You look younger than ever, love.
Younger than ever.
Hehehe.
Hier sehen wir schon
Ausfallerscheinungen.
James lallt und stolpert
durch die Gegend.
*Lachen*
Und wenn ihr denkt,
so schnell geht das nicht,
Alkohol braucht doch Zeit,
bis er ankommt.
Das ist ein gängiger Irrglaube.
Ja, es kann bis zu 60 min dauern,
bis der Alkohol sich
im ganzen Körper verteilt hat.
Aber im Gehirn
kommt er deutlich schneller an.
Er geht direkt
über die Blutbahn ins Hirn.
Er kann schon nach 3-5 Minuten
seine Wirkung entfalten.
Darum ist "Druckbetankung"
so gefährlich.
Der Körper meldet
normalerweise zurück,
dass er jetzt genug hat.
Er baut auch im Hintergrund
den Alkohol langsam wieder ab.
Bei Frauen ist das
etwa 0,1 Promille pro Stunde,
bei Männern etwas mehr.
Wenn wir das so machen wie James,
hat der Körper keine Zeit,
das zurückzumelden.
Und er kann den Alkohol
nicht parallel abbauen.
James kippt ja 4 Gläser Weißwein
zum Fisch weg.
Auch wenn die Becher
etwas kleiner sind,
also etwa 0,1 Liter,
100 ml sind da auf jeden Fall drin.
Wir haben insgesamt
0,4 Liter Weißwein.
Und wir haben
einen Alkoholanteil von ca. 12%.
Das kommt auf den Sherry
noch oben drauf.
Das sehen wir im Rechner deutlich.
Der Promillewert
geht rasant nach oben.
Wir sind nach dieser Runde 2
schon bei 1,2 Promille.
Da verändert sich was im Körper.
Ab 1 Promille können
die wenigsten Leute noch verbergen,
dass sie betrunken sind.
*Er lallt.*
Wir sind viel enthemmter.
Die Reaktionszeit
ist deutlich verlangsamt.
Die Reaktionen passen nicht mehr so,
wir fangen an zu lallen,
die Feinmotorik stimmt nicht mehr.
Aber gleichzeitig,
und das ist ein Problem,
trauen wir uns viel mehr zu.
Die meisten von uns,
wenn sie mal auf der Party
das ein oder andere Glas
zu viel getrunken haben,
die merken schon, dass sie
vielleicht übertrieben haben.
Und machen dann eben einfach
den Rückzug nach Hause.
Woran liegt das?
Was passiert in unserem Körper,
wenn wir Alkohol trinken?
Ganz vereinfacht kann man sagen:
Alkohol bringt das Gleichgewicht
bestimmter Botenstoffe durcheinander,
die dazu da sind,
Reize von Nervenzelle zu Nervenzelle
in unserem Gehirn weiterzugeben.
Dadurch verlangsamen sich
unsere Denkprozesse.
Und es werden Hormone ausgeschüttet,
die uns enthemmter
und ausgelassener machen.
Genau das ist das Angenehme
vom Alkohol.
Dass man sich etwas lustiger,
fröhlicher, freier fühlt.
Aber das kann ab einem gewissen Punkt
ziemlich schnell umschlagen.
Welche peinliche Suffgeschichte
habt ihr schon erlebt?
Schreibt mir das gern
in die Kommentare.
James muss leider
noch ein bisschen weitermachen.
Für den ist gerade mal Halbzeit.
*Lachen*
*Er lallt laut.*
Admiral von Schneider.
*Er lallt.*
James.
Skal.
*lautes Lachen*
Mr. Pommeroy.
Cheers, Officer.
Mr. Winterbottom.
(lallend) The nicest little woman.
Hicks.
(undeutlich)
For the nicest little woman.
*Wortfindungsstörungen*
*lautes Gelächter*
That's ever made.
I now declare the bazaar open.
*Klaviermusik*
Für James gibt es jetzt also
4 Gläser Champagner.
Aber da geht schon
die Hälfte daneben.
Gehen wir auch hier wieder von einem
gut gefüllten Shotglas von 4 cl aus.
Da sind wir bei 0,16 Liter.
Champagner hat einen Alkoholgehalt
von etwa 12%.
Wenn wir das wieder ausrechnen,
sind wir schon bei 1,4 Promille.
Kann er da, in diesem Zustand,
noch ganz normal um den Tisch laufen
und behutsam
über den Tigerkopf steigen?
Wenn man so schnell so viel trinkt,
ist ein Risiko,
dass man sich relativ schnell
erbrechen muss.
Ein Promille ist so der Bereich,
wo die Leute
ordentlich Übelkeit bekommen.
Gleichgewicht ist ein Riesenproblem.
Wenn James kein Hardcore-Trinker ist
und gut erfahren im Alkoholkonsum
kann es sein, dass ihm schon
ordentlich schwindlig ist.
Diese Bewegungen um den Tigerkopf
wären sicher schwierig.
Und man muss sagen: Je mehr James
an die 2 Promille-Grenze kommt,
desto schwieriger wird es für ihn,
die Koordination aufrechtzuerhalten.
Aber die Erfahrung,
die James mit Alkohol hat,
muss man ein bisschen einrechnen.
Aber ganz schön krass,
dass so ein alter Herr
sich mit 1,2 Promille
noch ganz gut auf den Beinen hält.
Was ich krass finde:
Menschen reagieren
so unterschiedlich auf Alkohol.
Während die eine Person
mit 1 Promille
noch fast normal drauf ist,
ist das für eine andere Person
schon fast Totalausfall.
Woran liegt das?
Zum Einen gibt es da
Geschlechterunterschiede.
Frauen und Männer sind dann doch
etwas unterschiedlich
zusammengesetzt.
Auch die Enzyme sind genetisch,
aber auch zwischen den Geschlechtern
unterschiedlich ausgeprägt.
D.h., wie unser Körper
den Alkohol verarbeiten kann.
Der wichtigste Effekt
ist aber der Gewöhnungseffekt.
Wenn ich einfach jeden Tag
viel Alkohol konsumiere,
gewöhnt sich der Körper
viel mehr daran.
Wie bei allen anderen Drogen
braucht man viel mehr,
um die gleiche Wirkung zu erzielen.
Also vielleicht steht James
einfach gut im Training.
Darauf muss er aber nicht
besonders stolz sein.
Denn Alkohol ist ein Zellgift
und tötet auch Nervenzellen,
wenn man über längere Zeit
zu viel davon trinkt.
Egal, wie gut er trainiert ist,
man sieht, dass er sich
durch den letzten Gang durchkämpft.
Das macht er auch ziemlich deutlich.
Sir Toby.
- ♪ Sugar in the morning.
Admiral von Schneider.
- Sch...kal.
*Gelächter*
Mr. Pommeroy.
A... Sorry, Ma'm, schorry.
*lautes Lachen*
Mr. Winterbottom.
Cheers.
Oh, I'll kill that cat...
An diesem Punkt des Abends
sorgt James schon selbst dafür,
dass er kaum noch etwas
zu Trinken bekommt.
Da geht so viel daneben,
dass von dem Portwein
vielleicht so ein großes Schnapsglas
in seinem Rachen landet.
Lasst uns bequemerweise
wieder mit 4 cl rechnen.
Portwein hat aber mehr Umdrehungen.
Wir sind bei 20% Alkoholgehalt.
Wenn wir das alles zusammenrechnen,
kommen wir auf einen Promillewert
von 1,6 am Ende des "Dinner for One".
Mit diesem Pegel bleibt James
noch eine letzte Aufgabe.
Good night, James.
I think I retire.
(lallend) Oh by the way, the same
procedure as last year, Miss Sophie?
The same procedure as every year,
James.
Well ...
... I'll do my very best.
*lautes Gelächter*
Na hoffentlich muss er da nicht
für alle Verstorbenen mit ran.
Sorry, aber würde er
zu diesem Zeitpunkt
überhaupt noch einen hochkriegen?
Naja ... also ...
eher unwahrscheinlich,
muss man ehrlicherweise sagen.
Wir kennen uns ja alle:
Geringe Mengen von Alkohol
führen dazu,
dass wir uns euphorischer fühlen,
dass man etwas enthemmter ist.
Das kann in solchen Situationen
durchaus hilfreich sein.
Aber bei so hohen Alkoholmengen
führt das meist nicht zu Euphorie,
sondern dass man ziemlich platt ist
bis hin zu tief bewusstlos.
Zugleich hat Alkohol
in höheren Konzentrationen
eine muskelerschlaffende Wirkung.
Und "schlaff" ist da schon
das richtige Wort.
Also, die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass James und Miss Sophie
sich da noch adäquat
vergnügen können im Schlafzimmer,
die ist eher ziemlich gering.
Also: Das "Dinner for One"
wäre für James,
wenn er in normaler medizinischer
Verfassung ist
und keine Medikamente nimmt,
jedenfalls nicht tödlich.
Aber es ist nicht gesund und
Miss Sophie hätte mehr Spaß mit ihm,
wenn sie ihn nicht dazu zwingen
würde, so viel Alkohol zu trinken.
Dann müsste er am nächsten Morgen
nicht mit einem Kater liegenbleiben,
sondern könnte ihr Kaffee
ans Bett bringen.
Danke, dass ihr
bis hierhin geschaut habt.
Danke auch an "Cinema Strikes Back"
für das schöne Intro
und an die NERDfall-Mediziner
fürs Erklären.
Lasst doch ein paar Grüße
auf deren Kanal von uns da.
Und schreibt uns hier,
ob ihr "Dinner for One"
dieses Jahr schon gesehen habt.
Ich fand, 2022 war ein fantastisches
Jahr und freue mich aufs nächste.
Wenn ihr nichts verpassen wollt,
dann drückt jetzt auf Abonnieren
und die Glocke.
Dann sehen wir uns bald wieder.
Rutscht gut rein, tschüssi.
Hey, Fans, hier oben gibt es noch
ein sexy Video
von "Cinema Strikes Back".
Und wenn ihr es
richtig krachen lassen wollt,
gibt es noch ein Video
von uns zu James Bond.
Miau.
Copyright MDR 2022